2016 is an important year for the BMW
group and March had celebrated its 100th
birthday to mark the centenary the BMW
Museum in Munich has put on a temporary
exhibition presenting the company's
history as exemplified in 100
masterpieces that testified to the
innovation and enterprise displayed in
various epochs
the company started out making aeroplane
engines in 1916 seven years later it
started making motorcycles in 1928 BMWs
first car made its debut the earliest
models were small and contemporary in
design at the Berlin Motor Show in 1933
BMW presented the 303
it's sported a new six-cylinder in-line
engine the interior was spacious the
saloon represented a shift from compact
to mid-range models the 303 was the
first car to sport the kidney grille
which would become a typical BMW feature
it had a ladder frame made from tubular
side members and box section cross
members which meant the car was
unusually light at the time the
consensus was that only heavy vehicles
had good road-holding
decks or not the director of the museum
gabriella think tells us that the
exhibits come from all over some were
donated by members of the BMW clubs many
others were very generously made
available by friends at various
exhibition halls and museums after the
Second World War the company had to
reinvent itself in many respects it only
resumed making cars in 1952 but it was
not very successful the breakthrough
came with the introduction of the 1500
unveiled in 1961 as the first model of
what BMW called its new class it was an
eye catcher with its modern dynamic
styling
the new class as a whole proved a huge
success with more than 350,000 units
sold by 1972
new class vehicles also took part in
races and often won an old advertisement
says Touring Car races are to this day
BMWs domain the list of BMW successes
keeps getting longer
Robert Hana won the European Touring Car
Championship in 1966 he was the first to
zip around the Nurburgring track in less
than 10 minutes at a touring car between
1919 and 1970 BMW won 321 World Records
373 championships and six thousand two
hundred eighty seven gold medals and
book nine thousand seven hundred sixteen
wins in various classes the four-door
sedan version of the 1500 with a new
four-cylinder 80 horsepower engine was
fast and sporting by 1971 an entire
model range had been created with a top
model packing 130 horsepower
experience on the racetrack is useful
for everyday driving - validated and
racing and reliability tests
and in everyday deriving me envy
in 1999 the BMW v12 LMR one philemon
Grand Prix Pierluigi martini drove the
580 horsepower beast in the grueling 24
hour race 366 times around the circuit
of 13 point 6 kilometers
it was the first Lomond victory for BMW
these are just a few of the exciting
stories and fabulous vehicles that can
be enjoyed at the 100 masterpieces
exhibition at the BMW Museum in Munich